never  ever put yourself in a situation where  you hurt your willpower never because  eventually the world businesses  companies families  anything is ran by leaders not because  they're talented not because they speak  better than everybody else not because  they're the best at reading books not  because they have the fanciest degree  because in a board room when this guy or  this gal says he or she is going to do  something you can bank it  you can cash the check baby and people  like that are not a dime a dozen they  are rarer than diamond you can rarely  find people like this and when you find  people like this you lock onto them  because they're going places